I'm joined today by Sean Flynn who is
the chair of the economics department at
Scripps College he's an entrepreneur he
studies free-market healthcare and is
also the best-selling author of
economics for dummies and he's also
running for Congress as a Republican and
Sean I've been following your work on
the Singapore healthcare system for a
long time and it's not often discussed
in the United States and the
conversations between sort of like a
total free market system which tends to
be favored by the American right versus
a sort of Medicare for All system or
single-payer system which is more
popular on the American Left talked a
little bit about the sort of primary
tenets of the Singapore health care
system well yeah David thank you so much
I guess that your intro is a great way
to slide into Singapore here because you
know we are very ideologically driven
when it comes to health care and social
reform in general in this country and
Singapore by contrast is just a total
pragmatist and so they've gone out and
collected various pieces and parts we
could discuss put them all together and
they're spending half as much as Canada
England France and about 75 percent less
than we are and they're covering every
one and they've got essentially the
world's best health care outcomes no
matter what statistic you look like or
they're you know they're in the top
three or four for everything and so I
think that's a good place to go is just
starting off with the non-ideological
nature of the system and just doing what
works to cover everyone yeah and they
have elements that are sort of more in
the for-profit free-market direction but
they also have some relatively I mean
hey heavy enough handed more
authoritarian style provisions that I
think would not be very palatable to the
American right can you talk a little bit
about how the system is structured sure
okay so one thing the American right and
I think most Americans would agree with
is you know we believe you know at least
all of us to some extent that markets
are the absolute best way to go in terms
of getting efficiency but that of course
you know there's other issues involved
than just efficiency but they've got
price tags on everything so you can go
to Singapore and say you needed a knee
surgery you could call around or go
online actually and just get the prices
for every awesome Pedic surgeon in the
country
which forces all the doctors to compete
against each other on both price and
quality and we know competition in
healthcare in the United States works
because we can point at things like
LASIK so anything here that is not
covered by our crazy insurance system
things like LASIK eye surgery cosmetic
surgery there treatments like laser
treatments for varicose veins anything
that we call elective is cash-and-carry
and free-market here and what you see is
prices falling year after year and you
see quality going up and so my favorite
example there is that LASIK eye surgery
used to be say 5000 an eyeball and you
can now find it for like 500 with a
Groupon right and you know a Groupon
means doctors are marketing they're
competing they're having to you know
figure out better ways to do anything so
Singapore has that so it's got price
tags and competition now the other two
that Shawn before we move on to the next
point to a drug that there is one other
factor also in Singapore that is working
to push prices down which is that
there's significant government
involvement in care right government is
a big player there in terms of the
hospitals and in other ways so again
it's sort of a blend of both ideas that
would be palatable to the left and right
okay so you're right about the
government so 80 percent of the acute
hospital beds right you know something
goes really wrong for you eighty percent
of the beds are in the big public
hospitals rather than private hospitals
but even there David so we need to
separate out the provision versus the
financing of healthcare so you're
absolutely right that the government is
doing a lot of the actual building of
the buildings and here's the hospital
but in terms of the finance and the
competition even those public hospitals
the way the financing works it's the
same system with the posted prices and
the competition between doctors and they
even made every public hospital with its
own independent nonprofit that can set
its own prices and can set its own you
know remuneration for the doctors and
staff so that even the public hospitals
have to compete against each other to
get people's business so it really is as
you say a remarkable blend but we need
to be careful there because the
healthcare finance assisting at least
this part with the prices and
competition it's system-wide including
the public hospitals so it's not as
though they're running one set of
competitive posted prices hospitals and
then there's another set that's
insulated from prices that happens to be
covered by the government the whole
system has this price pressure and
competition but the public and private
is it fair to say that you have a system
that in a sense would be like if I read
one line that if if Milton Friedman were
a socialist this would sort of be the
system he would have designed you know I
don't know who wrote that but um you
know given that Milton Friedman was
above all a practice trait you know I
wouldn't say you know even though his
reputation is hey I I'm a free market
guy at least in his own mind he was a
practical guy first and so whether he
would have been a socialist instead of
you know what we think it was this big
free-market advocate yeah I think this
would have been the first place you've
looked to because they're spending way
less than everyone and delivering way
care way better care to the entire
population like they don't shove their
veterans in a different system their or
their older people or poor people like
literally everyone's going to the same
hospitals and enjoying the same benefits
of their system so I think yeah that
would have had he been a socialist
appeal to him greatly what is the
connection if any between employment and
your employer in Singapore and your
health insurance um very very little if
it's there there are employers who are
for health care benefits but they're
above and beyond what is in the core
system and let me discuss that because
this goes back to finishing off your
your question earlier about their system
so one thing they have is all this price
transparency competition but you still
need to make sure that people have
access and so the way they do that in
Singapore and I would actually offer a
slightly different model for the United
States has been shown by you know state
of Indiana and work of Medicaid Whole
Foods Markets to work in the private
sector here but the core system over
there in terms of making sure there's
access is they first set up you know
what we call catastrophic insurance or
high deductible insurance here but then
they make sure everyone has a way to
actually pay their annual deductible
because as you know here with like
things like Obamacare bronze plans there
are a lot of people making $10 an hour
but they've got a $10,000 annual
deductible and in some sense they're
effectively uninsured even though
they're paying premiums they're not
going to have $10,000 to cover an annual
deductible stuff that's like that's the
core problem with any sort of high
deductible or catastrophic system okay
no message on let me just just so I'm
clear let me make sure I understand
where you're getting those numbers there
would be and and there is a maximum
yearly out-of-pocket that accounts both
for the deductible and the premium so
even though someone making 10 bucks an
hour on a bronze plan might on paper
have a ten thousand dollar deductible
their total yearly out-of-pocket would
be limited by the provisions that put a
maximum on how much relative to your
income you'd spend on health care in a
year yes effectively uninsured which
would defeat the entire purpose of the
you know the America of the Affordable
Care Act right and so you see the poor
they've got they've done it a slightly
different way but one that preserves the
incentives to always look around shop
around for the best deal
keep price competition and so what they
do there is there's a $2,000 year annual
deductibles basically the number and
then above that 10% copay all the way up
to infinity and so let them give me a
second there to show how people are
protected because that sounds dangerous
and so then what the government does to
make sure you've got some money in your
pocket at all times when you're born
they just give $3,000 over the health
savings account when you start working
you're required in Singapore to put
seven percent of your income every year
into a health savings account the
government's run properly so they
actually guarantee and four percent
interest so it's constantly accumulating
most people are quite healthy to learn
about my age mid-40s and so you have
these huge piles of health savings and
then people go out and they can cover
their annual deductibles and then they
can cover those co-pays and if for some
reason something goes really
catastrophic ly wrong and you know 10%
up to infinity means you could run out
of money right the government then has a
safety net there and they treat you
first and then you basically put in a
little grant application asking the
government hey I ran out of money could
you cover this and the answer there the
government that they approved ninety
nine point three percent of all the
applications so they've got this
rock-solid safety net in combination
with
health care system where there's
competition like even people are very
modest means there have money in their
pockets to actually go out and into a
consumer marketplace and put pressure on
the doctors to keep prices down because
they always have some skin in the game
yeah because they know any money they
don't spend out of that annual mm
adductor Bowl or that copay that 10%
above they get to keep and so that's the
other thing in their system that sort of
is the feedback mechanism that we've
currently lost in our system is there
isn't intense constant pressure by
consumers with their own bodies with
their own money to keep the providers in
line and providing things at low cost
and high quality yeah and this was the
next thing I wanted to talk about in
terms of you know just understanding
sort of the way the American political
spectrum sees this type of stuff which
is that mandatory health savings account
contribution I think it's a very very
interesting way to fund this and it's
not something that I'm against but you
would see particularly from members of
your party in the United States just
apoplectic nanny-state bs reactions to
that who's to tell me I need to put
aside 7 percent of my income for health
insurance even though of course we do it
with the first hundred and you know a
percentage of the first hundred and
twenty thousand we earn to Social
Security some some people have a problem
with that as well that would be a tough
pill to swallow for many in the United
States wouldn't it well I think so and
the fears might go even deeper to a
cynicism that says wow we've got all
these entitlement problems coming down
the line maybe they're gonna tell me
they're gonna take my health savings
account now but then later on they'll
redirected towards something else right
so there'd be a lot of political fears
yep so the way it's been handled here in
the United States is for instance Whole
Foods Markets they just make an annual
deposit in do their workers health
savings accounts right they just
essentially give to people or look from
the workers perspective it looks like a
gift there's this pile of money that
just goes in every year into their
health savings account and it
accumulates and there is told hey you've
also got high deductible coverage
catastrophic we gave you the amount of
the annual deductible anything you don't
spend you get to keep and that gives
them an incentive to shop around now of
course there are no price tags in their
system right so it's not you know all
these things put together but at least
the insurance company the way you handle
it here is instead of explicitly taxing
you just make it look like a gift right
it's their money on a total compensation
but it goes in their health savings
accounts and this is worked wonders you
know all across the income spectrum so
we have you know the example of the
healthy Indiana program that actually
was put in place in 2011 in the state of
Indiana and what they did there was they
had some extra tobacco tax revenue and
they said hey let's cover more working
for their people who currently are not
poor enough to qualify for Medicaid in
this state these are good people they're
working hard they're doing all the right
things we want them to move up and be
able to help their families so let's put
them into Medicaid but let's make it
look something like this this is what
Singapore does with the high deductible
and the annual deposits and so they
created a version of Medicaid there that
has an $1,100 per year annual deductible
which you might say oh my goodness if
someone you know working for very little
wages they can't afford that but then
the state also gifted each person $1,100
a year and so when you see that you
realize they're financially safe right
they've been given the $1,100 to cover
the annual deductible and then of course
it's Medicaid anything above the 1100 is
all on the government so these people
are equally financially safe and secure
is anyone on normal Medicaid where
there's you know first dollar coverage
right Medicaid approves it all spending
is in normal Medicaid starts with the
first dollar all the way up so it's
hundred-percent here you've got an
annual deductible but you give people
the amount of the annual deductible and
what you find when you put people into a
system like that and you tell them any
money you don't spend is money you get
to keep out of that annual deductible
next year there'll be another eleven
hundred and the third year another
eleven hundred when you tell people that
whether they're on Medicaid or there are
whole foods employee and we've got
randomized experiments I could point to
health care spending Falls by about a
third thirty to thirty five percent just
by people shopping around for the best
deal and you know not you know I used to
have you know through martial arts all
the time then I would always go and get
everything x-rayed even though I knew it
was almost nothing because I had a ten
dollar copay right but once it becomes
your own money you're a little more
cautious and he had the great rooms but
at the same time Sean I mean I want to
push back a little because it's been
pretty widely studied that the the myth
of people overusing healthcare merely
because they don't pay anything out of
pocket by and large people have lie
they're not just looking to get
procedures done for the sake of it and
big picture if a system is going to work
or not going to work I don't believe
it's going to be determined whether it
works or not by people saying hey you
know what since it's covered I'm gonna
go get procedures done and see doctors
well okay so I can you know don't mean
to stumble over my words here but I can
point you to overwhelming evidence
starting with the largest randomized
trial that was done by the RAND
Corporation over like 15 years and then
starting in the 1970s there's the
ongoing org and health insurance
experiment which was a full
randomization of Medicaid patients I can
actually point you to a ton of evidence
that says people cut back on their
spending about by 1/3 yeah but I think
what's missing from those studies in the
ones I've seen anyway is that it doesn't
account for the long-term cost savings
that the system experiences because some
of that stuff people are choosing to do
is going to prevent more expensive
conditions and treatment down the line
okay so that is the argument I could
show you the stuff I've seen in these
things for instance in the state of
Indiana they intentionally exempted all
the long-term care stuff and I could
point you to another Indiana thing where
it was state government employees
starting at 2007 the people are going in
for mammograms just as often the people
were going in for the annual treatment
you know the annual checkups just as
often I could go on with a whole bunch
of these yeah honestly looks these David
you're you're right you're right to be
suspicious about that but all the
evidence I've seen says it looks like
the people are going in for all the
preventative maintenance of the exact
same rate and and even with that Rand
Health Study back in the 70s they follow
people both before 5 years when they
were 5 to 10 years when they were in and
another 5 years after and except for
very minor things like the difference
between 20 26 and 2027 vision there were
no statistically significant differences
in health outcomes and this is a
little-known fact and I know people
should be very suspicious on this point
but all the evidence I've seen and I
looked hard yeah I really did is I
actually didn't believe in the Singapore
thing or any of this stuff I actually
came to this as a total doubter when I
first heard about it back in 2009 and
was honestly baffled at first when I
kept
then I had to fly to Singapore to
confirm that well it seems to work over
there and I kept going back and forth
but honestly David there's a pile of
evidence that that's not actually a
problem and let me give you just one
statistic so in the state of Indiana
with the government employees when
people were on PPOs or HMOs and they had
the choice between here's the expensive
brand-name drug and here's the
generically equivalent I'm sorry the
chemical equivalent generic drug when
they were on PPOs or HMOs and it was
someone else's money ninety three
percent of the time they've gone for the
more expensive one when you switch them
over into this you know this sort of
singapore's looking system with a high
deductible insurance and that you know
the gift of the annual deductible did
that fell from 93 percent of the time
choosing the expensive version of the
Jordan down to only 13 so you see these
massive sea changes in behavior that cut
the cost without cutting care and I
could give other examples like yeah I
know that I mean that's interesting I'm
open to being convinced of that you know
I just I'm not seen the evidence but I
want to look forward and I want to see
what what that is
I specifically with the Indiana data I'm
just not familiar with that data so I'm
open to looking at that Shawn this is
super interesting we are out of time and
I do want to tell people that you know
not not a ton of Republicans in our
audience but if people do want to find
out more about your campaign on issues
other than health care of what's the
best place for them to do that so the
website might be the best place to start
and they can find all the state of the
links for your Facebook everything so
that's my full name Sean Flynn mor
Congress Cohn so SE AMF ly and and Sean
Flynn fo our Congress com thank you